top gun maverick it has a little
appetizer you can watch the original
it's this week's cbs saturday night
movie and just in case you forgot oh e.t
was on the set of the og film
who didn't grow up wanting to fly an
f-14 it's very easy falling into the
role i am dangerous
i feel it's some of my best work tom
called it top gun would become the
highest grossing film of 1986 earning
over 350 million and 36 years later its
quotes still live on i feel the need
for me
for speed
take me to bed or lose me forever show
me the way home buddy
[Music]
that was a line uh we got uh
from one of the pilots i mean there's no
time to think up there if you have to
think you're dead if you think
you're dead top gun had it all karaoke
fast motorcycles and an unforgettable
slo-mo beach volleyball scene
but some things you might not know about
the film
this love scene was actually added after
production rap it had to be shot in
silhouette because kelly mcgillis had
dyed her hair brown for her next role
same goes for why she wore a hat in the
elevator the female lead in
an all-male cast that's great
i feel like camp counselor
while the role of maverick was written
for tom he originally turned it down
multiple times other stars reportedly
considered for the role rob lowe charlie
sheen and robert downey jr oh and this
iconic scene i can't hear you
[Music]
yep tom had never ridden a motorcycle
before shooting this film don't you see
yourself as being the the sex symbol
that the audience does
not really no of course aside from
anthony edwards and meg ryan who dated
in real life after the film wrapped val
kilmer and tim robbins i'm bringing a
bit closer merlin we're gonna do what
the film's other stars were the f-14s it
won't be all blue screen with
fake jets flying around us will really
be up there real top gun pilots were
actually on set to make sure everything
was authentic do these hollywood types
really have the right stuff to be top
gun
they're trainable barely we'll just have
to see a-listers attended the film's new
york premiere including cher who dated
both tom and val in the mid 80s it's
very exciting it's very american i think
it'll be a very beautiful movie and it's
very inspiring all the actors
we all had a great time
[Music]
you